all right oh and Chris welcome to
Fandango frontrunner happy to be hot you
will see two orange chairs oh yeah those
are the front-runner chair oh man like a
that's taking over this entire movie
theater just for you
Chris and Phil welcome to offend angle
frontrunner thank you so much for
joining me today thanks for having us
I vividly remember walking into the
screening of the lego movie and thinking
to myself there's probably nothing for
me here but hopefully I'll find some fun
moments right cut you terrible attitude
I don't go into a screening got to right
now it's one of my two or three favorite
movies of 2014 no question wow thank you
guys feel like low expectations from
some people we're kind of your best
friend for this movie they have been our
best friend and throughout our careers
yeah I mean everything we've done from
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs said
21 Jump Street to doing 22 Jump Street
and lego movie have all been I don't
know that sounds like a bad idea
yeah if you ever walk into a screening
of something we've made with high
expectations you know that the fall is
about to happen so why are your idea so
horrible it's like how some women are
attracted to like bad boys like we're
only attracted to like really hard ideas
yeah
really hard broken birds we can save
them we can save these ideas right now
you're at this incredible moment with
the success of Lego with the success of
the Jump Street movies but take me back
a little bit was there a moment earlier
on where you guys had a feeling that you
could be on to something really special
when we were in college together and we
both made these student animated films
and we were helping each other out
and spending our entire lives making
these these dumb little shorts through a
series of comical misunderstandings I
end up getting a call in my dorm room
from an executive at Disney who had seen
an article that was written about me in
the Dartmouth alumni magazine it claimed
that I had like designed the dinosaurs
for the new Star Wars and with that and
the fact that they didn't have dinosaurs
and I had nothing to do with that wasn't
when I said that you'd be so rich now
yeah my buddy and I were gonna graduate
we've been making these films I'll send
them to you and we'll meet we're
planning on moving out to LA anyway and
see if we can make a go of it we'll meet
then but then after I hung up I was like
wow maybe maybe it might work what about
you feel what moment sticks out as a
moment
you thought you could make it when I was
younger they ran out of books in the
elementary school that I went to so our
reading group at read through the sixth
grade write a book people ate them they
ate them yeah it was a dystopian past
there's a lot of dystopian future for
this is a dystopian past that I lived in
where there was no food and only books
to eat but the but they ran out of books
and so they didn't know what to do with
us so they gave us a video camera that
the librarian had and we were making our
own comic books me and a couple of
friends there was a character named
Captain [ __ ] muffle which was an
acronym for sure I'll solve your mystery
for you little lady
and anyway that was the main hero and we
made a commercial for the comic books
the comic books were not very good but
the commercial was fairly impressive
okay so now is the time in the show
where we look at a scene from the lego
movie okay together and we'll pause it
and talk about all the great moments
this is near the beginning of the movie
where we really learn about Emmet the
main character and life in bricks bird
scored to the fantastic song everything
is awesome so let's take a look oh my
gosh I love this song and I'm stopping
already because so much has already
happened I'm a huge Tegan and Sara fan
so I personally am NOT sick of
everything is awesome you're on what are
you not sick of it I'm enjoying it more
now than ever because why well we wrote
this line in the script five years ago
that was like there will be a song
called everything is awesome and it will
be a horrible song but it will be so
catchy that you can't stop singing it
and then actually it will get really
popular like the essence of pop I'll set
now we're looking at this crazy shot
here which idea have to imagine is one
of the most elaborate seconds in the
entire weight a lot ya know it's like it
like 10,000 cars on a de freeway and
even like there's some on the bottom of
the screen that's a little blurry and
then some that's more in focus yeah a
shallow depth-of-field was a really
complicated thing because when you're
doing miniature photography it's really
hard to keep you know everything in
focus and and when you're doing
something in 3d it's really nice to keep
everything in focus because you can look
around the screen but it doesn't look
real we want to make sure it look like
something you could really do at home if
you had that many Lego bricks and you
had a really good lighting team that you
could make it yourself and so it was
really important to us that we had a
shallow depth of field and it was a
little bit of a fight but I'm glad that
I'm glad that we were able to pull it
off I love it let's keep going
always use a turn signal now I love the
turn signal because it has this stop
motion feel to it and I have read that
you guys were really into combining kind
of like a low and a high method of
animation in this manners I think part
of the charm
part of the joy for us was like here's
you're using the most sophisticated
technology in the history of cinema
right all this like incredible rendering
software and all this stuff but the
animation that's going on is literally
just replacing a clear colored brick
with an amber colored brick back and
forth which is the simplest possible
solution so a big thing with the
animators was conveying to them the idea
that we should go for the dumbest
possible solution whenever possible so
we could never do stuff that you could
do in CG like bend the arms of the
characters they had to stay stiff
because we were more interested in how
you would solve the problem of like how
do you I can't drink
they can't clap I can't like thing up to
their face they can't clap so they do
stuff like this I see okay Park between
the lines yes drop off dry cleaning
before noon read the headline now with
something like that words read the
headlines and you have all those
different banners do you guys put little
Easter eggs in little secret jokes many
we do there's many there all throughout
the movie the one regret that I have
that we talked about that thank goodness
we're making a sequel is we were going
to embed subliminal messages that were
incredibly instead of being satanic
we're going to be like super positive
yeah like what listen to your parents
like do your homework
like cuz we were like well we're making
this thing for kids and it's with this
you know this toy that really is so good
for kids brains like let's make a movie
that's got like great positive messages
I did not do it well we got busy don't
forget to smile always root for the
local sports team
always return a compliment hey you look
nice you when I saw this for the first
time I felt like the jokes were just
whizzing in the best possible way and it
was the rare case when as soon as it was
over I said to myself I cannot wait to
see this again was that part of your
goal to have it go that fast and furious
well we're always kind of embarrassed
about our jokes especially if ago here's
a joke right yeah they don't want to
just like put a big pause for laugh
afterwards right and we want to do
something that would reward you multiple
viewings and so that was sort of part of
the philosophy the whole thing here's
the end of the scene drink overpriced
coffee go that's $37 awesome you know we
have to talk about Chris Pratt because I
feel like he was such a great teammate
for you and all of his inflections are
so energetic and charming it must have
been fun to watch him do it you know
we've known him and have been a fan of
him for a long time we worked with his
wife on Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs but he was always such a
positive guy and such like I've just
like a happy person who always made us
laugh and we were thinking of this
character was like what's kind of like
Chris Pratt and he we were lucky and at
that time it was like you think they'll
let him star in a movie right yeah and
now he's like literally the hottest
movie star in the business and it was
really obvious in the way we cast these
things is we cut together clips of
people from shows and things like that
just audio we listened to it and so it
was really evident from Chris's audition
which he didn't know he was auditioning
that it was that he had to be the guy
well for two guys who are known for
having horrible ideas that was a glibly
one that turned out to be really good
pretty good year congratulate you on
this movie I hope the Academy takes note
of it as much as I have and as much as
the whole world has so very well done oh
thank you so much thanks so much for
being here now if you haven't already
seen the lego movie be sure to check it
out
thanks so much to the TCL Chinese
Theatre for having us here today
and thank you for watching Fandango
frontrunners to say thank you we have
made each of you your own Fandango lego
movie gift card oh wow thank you so much
well that's very kind of you wonderful
thank you so much
and now we do a picture over here yeah
sure all right I'm gonna count to three
and then I'm gonna push it one two three
yes I love it